hey everyone this is Steve blancho with
collider we're here in the Sundance
Studio our Sundance Studio which is
being sponsored by Saratoga Spring Water
uh it's really expensive to come to
Sundance I really appreciate having
sponsors and I'm saying thank you
um so I'm here with the filmmaker writer
director and stars of polite society and
I really want to start with us and see
how much I I really loved your movie and
I'm so happy that it got great reviews
here at Sundance and it played huge I'm
just really happy for you guys but
before we get into talking about it I
think we have to talk about the most
important thing which is someone met
Anne Hathaway
I met on Hathaway guys
I'm never gonna shower again she hugged
me
it's really nice seeing people like
that's one of the things I love actually
about Sundance when doing a studio is
when people meet people that they're
fans of
um and obviously hopefully she'll see
your movie uh but it is it weird like
meeting someone like that guy I don't
know how many people you've met that are
like you know what I mean like that
you're a fan of and then all of a sudden
you're just meeting them
um yeah and not it doesn't happen very
often I mean I feel lucky to work with
people that I admire so I remember
meeting these guys for the first time
and being like Oh my God B shell this is
gonna be fine
um but are we Anne Hathaway
no no no no no no
[Laughter]
most people the trailers online for the
film so people can get a taste of it but
most people watching this interview
won't have seen the movie yet so how
have actually you've been how have you
been describing it to like friends and
family I I've just been describing it
with great difficulty because it's a
genre bending mad movie but
and it's really their love story and
it's their kind of breaking up and
coming together you know with a bit of
heist thrown in with a bit of kung fu in
there it's a it's a big blend um but
ultimately it's a film about Sisterhood
I'd say
do you guys want to add anything
you put that in a very good way about
the film
so I can't I can't imagine what it was
like for the two of you reading this
script for the first time because it's
unlike like I watch a lot of movies I
have not seen this movie before so what
was it like for the two of you reading
this for the first time or hearing about
it you know what I mean
Bonkers it's kind of mad
um I was laughing a lot reading it and I
think the the story of the sisters and
the fact that it is a love story between
them it really spoke to me I felt like I
related to it and I understood it and I
connected to it instantly so I was like
I need I need to be a part of this this
is so cool so yeah yeah I feel like well
I had worked with neither a couple times
before so even before reading it I was
like I know I want to be part of this
and then reading it it was just as crazy
as I thought it would be um which I
loved and um yeah super funny
heartwarming
um and I was just like ugh I'd really
drawn to my character I'm excited to
like see what I could bring like off
bring her off the page and
um just like no I just knew it would be
such a fun shoot
so yeah it also I mean because of what
you guys do on screen there is uh
there's just a lot you know what I mean
and like a lot it's not just delivering
lines it is you know it's a
three-dimensional role in every possible
way so I can't imagine like the
physicality of doing the shoot and
everything that went on so can you sort
of talk a little bit about behind the
behind the scenes
oh my gosh I feel like I completed an
entire CV and this in this job I scaled
buildings did dances and then Kung Fu I
I feel like I I like check so many boxes
riding bikes and like you name it
um so it was so fun there was a lot of
prep involved and we did a lot of stunt
and fight practice in the build up to it
it was class like around six seven weeks
before we started shooting so it was an
immediate Deep dive into everything
because I wanted to do as much of it as
possible but it was so much fun and I
will say that Priya is the next Tom
Cruise because she did so many of her
own stunts and like on set sometimes
last five minutes of the day and we're
all like we kind of get the shot we've
got to get the shot she's just like
Teamwork Makes the Dream work and then
like gets in the wire and does a
backflip and like I was just like what
did you did she do it and we were like
kind of in a shop and she's just like
incredible so I've got to say that to
put that out there thanks that
what was it like
oh um it was amazing it was a such a fun
experience I think the atmosphere the
atmosphere on set was just like a
playground we were just singing and
dancing and fooling around and I think
like but in professional way
incredibly like never like just creates
this amazing atmosphere that's full of
love and support and everything else was
so special about it is that the cast
just felt like family and so it was
really easy it didn't feel like work we
just came and we played with each other
um not in a weird way yeah in a crazy
way one of the things though that I
really enjoyed about the film is your
choices with editing I liked how you cut
on some dial like you you it wasn't
smooth Transitions and so and I really
dug that so can you talk about how you
came up with was that in the script or
did you figure all that out in the
editing room some of it was in the
script other you know some of it I've
got to give credit to my editor Robbie
Morrison he's I'm sure he'll watch this
he loves he loves collider
um you know I think a lot of it we found
in post and it just took you know it
took fine tuning with with any comedy
you know so much of it was editing
re-cutting putting it up in front of
audience is seeing if it lands going
back to the drawing board and and yeah
it was a it was a process this film has
gone through so many iterations you know
it's been 10 years since I wrote the
first draft to now so it's just been
constantly evolving and it's like fine
you know I've been able to gain skills
as a comedy writer and improve my yeah
improve my skill set so I feel like I've
been able to just hone in on how I want
the film to to play but also just
working with Incredible collaborators
that's not only actors who deliver the
lines with like amazing timing but also
just the crew across the board it's
meant that you know it makes my writing
look good
and I think also with the like the crew
and like majority of the cast that there
was so many women like on set that
something felt really special about that
too and like the I guess it's like the
team that you brought in it just felt
like so much empowerment for us like
like and it created like a Sisterhood on
like on set as well well that's one of
the things I actually
uh was so excited to see is that you
don't generally see the this this kind
of film being made with women kicking
ass like that like it's listen that's
one of the reasons why I thought it was
such such a special film I I am curious
one more editing question if you don't
mind how did it actually change in the
editing room in ways you weren't
expecting
oh much and I actually
and it's not like I'm trying to Pander
to audiences but it was finding out
where things were Landing where I could
improve where I could bring audiences
with me so oftentimes it was like
needing a music cue to help the edit or
having to edit you know go into slow
motion to really stylize a moment so it
didn't feel too brutal you know a lot of
the editing was actually to sort of
finesse the tone
um as well as like doing finding how
things landed but you know a lot of the
comedy some of the biggest laughs were
unintended which I don't want to admit
but I'm like sometimes it's just out of
your hands yeah okay it was like really
weird watching it yesterday night and
like the audience were laughing a bit so
I thought were like quite heartwarming
and I'm like what is this what's going
on this is really intense like why is
everybody
[Music]
yeah
I'm curious which scenes these were but
I want to actually ask it specifically
because I believe it's in the trailer so
I'll talk about it I'm trying to stay
spoiler free but you guys are eating I
believe a burger in a scene
um I think that's in the trailer and so
I I love talking to actors about one
eating scenes because they can be
challenging because you have multiple
takes and you actually chew the food
like do you swallow the food like are
you hungry I'm a huge fan of eating
scenes yeah
I'm like get me the food this is the
best excuse just like pig out yeah
um yeah no I'm I'm and I love watching
actors eat on on screen I'm like yes
quite that burger I think even with that
cheeseburger like you were like like
really go for it and then we did and she
was like tone it down yeah
[Laughter]
read it
uh one of the things though about this
film is that you you touched on the tone
a little bit like it starts in a certain
way and you're building towards what
this film becomes and it's it's one of
the reasons why I dug it is that it
doesn't follow the conventional
structure like it it had it moves to its
own Rhythm which which of course you
have to find in editing room and when
you're making it and it's not easy so
what which sequel like can you talk a
little bit about because the third act
becomes more yes you know what I'm
saying I'm trying to talk without
talking yeah you know what I mean though
yeah you know the third Act is why I
wanted everything to be like batshit
like like you know we kicked it up to it
you turned it up to 11. and and I knew I
had to build to that point so it's
always just trying to make sure each
sort of act each moment we're just
pushing it more we're just pushing it
more so by the time we get there the
audience is sort of primed for Insanity
um and again like you say you know it
just took a lot of work in the edit to
find it it was I think it was there on
the page but really in the edit with the
help of the music with the help of a
stylized costume the help of just
everyone out like the design that
everything working together to just kind
of push it to that final final Act uh
you also have titles
um like and so I'm curious was that
always in the script how did you decide
you wanted to do that you know the
titles weren't in the script but it and
it ended up giving you know because I
knew I wanted the film to feel like a
tale to feel like some sort of fable but
like an insane one that when we started
putting the titles in and the chapter
headings it just added a sense of Comedy
a playfulness again it helped lighten
the tone help set the tone and that was
something we found in in the edit and
actually writing those titles was like
one of the most fun about a whole war in
the edit Suite which is like insane
tiles
uh I could be mistaken I think I'm right
this is like your first real big role
and so like what what was it like
actually making like where you know what
I mean like I'm sure you had some
inclination of what making a movie like
this would be about or what it would be
like but wouldn't end up surprising you
about the process uh and being you know
a lead in a movie like this
oh my everything was so new to me
um I don't know if I found anything like
super like shocking I I really tried to
like look into it as much beforehand and
like reach out to people for advice and
see what I could gain from outside just
to like prep myself as well as I could
um and also I think like the credit of
feeling comfortable really just goes to
the car like the crew and the production
and all the cast I just felt so
supported like nobody made me feel like
I had to worry or that there was so much
pressure on my shoulders to have to
deliver on you know and and number one
on the course sheet like what does this
mean nobody ever made me feel like that
and it just was so easy like I do what I
love every single day so you just come
in you have the best time and you don't
mind working like crazy hard it doesn't
even feel like you're working just like
playing and um but I really was like so
determined to be a sponge I felt like it
was the only way to kind of eliminate
and and like counteract The Imposter
syndrome that I was feeling the entire
way through I was like you know I
remember sitting in the in the table
read and I was it was the first time I
was like oh my God I am the least
experienced person in this room and I so
desperately want to feel that I'm on a
Level Playing Field with all of my peers
I want to be able to deliver for them
and and I just knew that the only way
that I could do this was to use this
opportunity and and take like learn from
all of these incredible people like I
admire their careers and their talent so
what a better situation to learn in so
cool and I gotta say like you know
prio's number one on the call sheet is a
new actor but whenever she walked on set
she just lifted the entire crew entire
car she would say hello good morning to
the grips to the Sparks just would speak
to everyone and it made everyone raise
their game it made me raise my game you
know all these like grizzled tired film
people were like uh and then Prius is a
great full joyful presence and we're
like come on guys we're lucky to do this
job just a reminder that like hey we
don't have to be moody and sad
um I
think also can I just say she was so
super confident like you'd never think
that you were like the least experienced
person it was like we were learning from
you too like we was amazing such a Love
Fest I'm here for it I I read something
and this could be very wrong so I
apologize so I read that you were
working at a pharmacy and then decided
that you wanted to go to acting school
is this true or not true it's like sort
of not really
um
I worked in healthcare like
Communications I worked with
pharmaceutical companies so I think the
pharmacy thing was like a derivation or
like some you know but um yeah I studied
science I did like a normal office nine
to six Monday to Friday you know and I
but I have all I when I you could have
asked me when I was four years old what
do you want to be and I would have said
I wanted to be an actress and it's the
one thing that I've kept constant in my
life even if it was like an after-school
thing or like you know um joining clubs
or whatever so I did part-time evening
like I studied acting part-time in the
evenings for three years whilst I worked
for three years and then finally I was
like don't know why I'm I'm not doing
the thing that I want to be doing and
seven months later I got I got the call
so that was pretty cool I mean
it's amazing actually because I think
about all the people that you know what
I mean it's it uh getting a acting as a
lottery sometimes you know oh my gosh
absolutely you know I mean um I I think
it's going to be one of my last
questions or possibly last question uh
I'm curious for you what this experience
has been like when you compare it to
like umbrella and other things you've
worked on you know um making this one
I mean I think I'll always do the same
sort of like
work whether it's a low or high budget
movie or a player like whatever I think
so for that it never feels different but
for this like I said it was is the team
that's behind it and the energy just
felt so special
um and easy so I think you can feel that
in the film
um so I think that's really the takeaway
from it that was yeah different about
this one I lied I do have one other
question I'm looking at you you you
obviously like hit a home run with this
and I'm curious if you have other like
scripts that you've you know you know
what I mean like what are you thinking
about in terms of what you want to do
next oh mate I mean I've got we are lady
Parts series two which I'm I'm doing
next I'm very much enjoying but you know
I just had such a blast doing genre
doing action I want to do more action
movies I want more cool sort of women of
color at the center like I've got this
big historical epic I want to do set an
inch in a rock
yeah so I'm excited I have big Ideas
which I've been putting the draw because
like No One's Gonna No One's Gonna Give
me the money to make this film but let's
just keep that there and now I'm like
guys guys somebody throw money at me
um but you know what I mean though like
because the toughest part from I'm not a
filmmaker but every filmmaker tells me
the toughest part is you gotta make it
show what you can do on with this amount
of money yeah and then if people like it
you know someone hopefully will give you
a little bit more and let you you know
tell another story yeah and you know
just kind of plugging away and hoping to
get to do more cool movies with great
people
on that note I got to stop I could ask
you a million other things about when
the movie's coming out I'll do more
interviews talking about specifics
um on that note uh thank you so much for
coming in and um congrats for being at
Sundance thank you so thank you